according to a mckinsey report
automation and ai will lift productivity
and economic growth but millions of
people worldwide may need to switch
occupations or upgrade skills
between 2015 and 19 the number of
enterprises implementing ai grew 270
percent
however 54 of enterprises said that
skill shortages in a.i were the biggest
challenge facing their organization
that is why udacity has developed the ai
engineer using microsoft azure
nanodegree program
this nanodegree program is a great fit
for engineers solution architects or
data scientists who are looking to move
into a more ai-centric role
students will learn how to design and
build an end-to-end ai solution with
azure cognitive services design a
security strategy that aligns with
organizational policies and compliance
frameworks and how to deploy monitor and
manage continuous improvement of an
azure ai solution
by the end of this course you will have
completed three projects that showcase
your competency in microsoft azure
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
enhance your ai skills now with
udacity's ai engineer using microsoft
azure nanodegree program